while the first season is like a family
drama horror
this season is more like a a gothic
you know dark moody romance or a
very tragic love story
we're gonna break down that perfectly
splendid
season finale um so the kids had
traveled to
america with uncle henry and their
memories of blind manor kind of fade
away
and they hear this love story
disguised as a ghost story on the eve of
flora's
wedding um victoria when you found out
that the big twist is that
the gardener is actually the narrator
what was your reaction
i thought it was quite clever um i
thought it was
a great way to start this this story
and equally a a a beautiful reveal
um to end it i feel like
jamie and danny are about to become
2020's
biggest couple fans are going to fall
head over heels for these two women
victoria what do you think it is about
their relationship that's going to be so
captivating for fans
i'm glad you asked i really
hope that that's true because i think as
we're
we're just like culturally like there's
a cultural discussion around
relationships toxic relationships what's
a healthy relationship what serves me
how am i kind of breaking out of these
the way in which i was raised to pursue
like uh uh my authentic
self what what's the environment that
can cultivate that for me
um and i think in terms of
jamie and danny is that unlike peter and
rebecca they don't have any delusions
that they've you know
met their soul mate or that the other
one is perfect in some way
you know their day by day cooperating
and learning each other and building
trust
um which i just i don't think we see
enough of that i think it's i think it's
really special
i mean nell and arthur were also
beautiful healthy
love story as well yes but we don't get
to see as much of them but yeah no i
love
i love i love danny and jamie
and and and i really i hope people yeah
respond to it as well henry do you think
that
your character henry ever told flora and
miles
about his true relationship with their
mother they
they have such an undeniable family
chemistry do you think he ever confessed
that to them
i think so eventually you know it's it's
hard to say because uh
uh you know henry was uh is a very
staunch
english fellow so who who knows how far
he
he came out of his shell in the end but
i like to think that he
he redeemed himself to to them both
victoria let's talk about the body
snatching rules because i think we need
to clear some things up for people
so it's you it's me it's us
let a spirit enter a body but then flora
and miles were able to
push miss jessalyn peter out why do you
think that danny
wasn't able to push out the lady in the
lake if you learn anything in episode 8
it's that the lady of the lake doesn't
let go
[Music]
it was so much fun to get to see kate so
much
in episode eight um victoria were you
able to be on set at all and get to kind
of interact with your former sister
yeah like one day i was able to be there
for like a couple minutes
but and it was incredible because
imagine just walking into this house
that we had been shooting in and now all
of a sudden it's actually decorated
in its original um glory
uh and everybody's dressed in these
incredible
huge costumes that my friend lynn
falconer worked tirelessly on so to see
that all come to life
was absolutely spectacular um but no i
didn't get to spend much time on set
with kate now
mike flanagan is the keeper of all the
secrets henry once you finished
this season and all the scripts did you
have any lingering questions for him
i'm always kind of satisfied with uh
and mike talks a lot about the the world
that uh you know the story exists in
in the rehearsal time and and so
your unanswered questions are are pretty
much
laid to rest in the early stages but
it's
always exciting to watch the series
in the end because you know obviously i
wasn't there every day
and i didn't interact with some
storylines
and things like that so yeah i have a
few
unanswered questions now that i'm gonna
ask mike
when i have a chance what's one of them
that you have it actually came up
earlier because there was like a
question about
like the possession and
[Music]
the spirit thing the spirit rule right
yeah
so uh so i'm gonna field that but i bet
he has an answer
i just bet definitely yeah what can you
guys tell us about season three if there
is one will you be back
victoria i don't know nothing
really yeah would you come back
yeah sure yeah sure it's an anthology
now
so theoretically we could come back so i
would come back
what is the one thing that you want to
tell fans who have just finished
binging this series what do you want to
say to them as they're
rolling the credits sorry i love you got
a whole set that's a hill that's a copy
of hill house right
it is now that's your house yeah
i think i have that cover i have a few
cops i had to pay homage
sorry what were you saying no uh but
just as fans have finished watching
blind manor what is the one thing that
you want to say to them
the end
[Laughter]
i'll take it i'll take it
[Music]